ran out it's just a way of showing you
know you can't you can't speak that way
i love trey hogan i think
he's sending a great message thank you
trey very effective
very effective so we are marking the
100th anniversary this month of the
ratification of the 19th amendment
while it gave all women the right to
vote most black women could not vote
until the civil rights movement of the
1960s
on this historic centennial we're
exploring the long struggle for full
equality
usa today is highlighting women who have
paved the way
in its women of the century project this
is a great idea susan page
is the washington bureau chief for usa
today and joins us to discuss hey susan
page
good to see you hey gail how you doing
i'm good you know why i'm good because
you and i can both
vote you're white i'm black i'm just
glad that we have we can
finally go to the polls together should
we choose and cast our vote
so what what do you think we can learn
from history when we look at this moment
you know black women were beaten
and arrested and jailed for the right to
vote
you know it was i think one thing we
should remember is this was not
easy we saw suffragettes getting
arrested and beaten estranged from their
families
imprisoned force-fed in prison susan b
anthony
tried for the crime of voting convicted
in a trial where she couldn't testify
because she was female
this has been a long struggle and an
especially long struggle for women of
color
yeah and some people say that that
struggle still continues today you know
stacey abrams has that whole big
campaign about
you know fighting against voter
suppression still very scary times as we
sit here in 2020
on the eve of a presidential election
and absolutely right voting rights still
a big issue and what we see one thing
happening this year
women as the driver of this election you
know women have been
reached new levels of activism they've
become
candidates in record numbers and they're
really the voting group that we see the
two presidential candidates
focused on as they look toward november
gail yeah we were talking about 2018 a
record number of women won
office across the country what impact do
you think that we'll have as we go to
the polls in 2020
you know i think it has an impact to
have women as candidates this is the
year we have kamala harris
on the national ticket just the third
woman ever nominated for vice president
if that ticket wins
she'd be the first woman to become
either president or vice president our
country that would be
definitely a breakthrough it's it's
these are changing times for women and
we see
kamala harris being treated in different
ways than the previous
three women who have been on national
tickets not a perfect system
but one that's changing different ways
how
well you know i remember i actually
covered the 1984 campaign
when geraldine ferraro became the first
woman on a national ticket
and i remember the endless debates about
what she would wear
and whether she and walter mondale would
would hug
each other and you know that's the kind
of debate that we it's not that we're
not having any uh sexist debates today
that is a debate we have gotten passed
well it's susan it's anthony mason
it's interesting that a number of of
prominent women have have announced that
if they
if that com if it becomes that
conversation or in any way she is
targeted in in kind of a
derogatory way that they are going to
come out in defense of her
uh and and and so there's obviously a
clear effort to to change the
conversation here
you know anthony that's exactly right
and it changed just in the last four
years i think
a lot of women were distressed by some
of the treatment
of hillary clinton when she became the
first woman ever nominated
for president and i think a
determination that some of those attacks
are going to be addressed in a much more
direct way
than they were four years ago we were
talking about the
the big piece that you've done in usa
today there are some names we know of
course like rosa parks
did you have one or two that stood out
for you that we might not know that you
think
you guys should know about this person
hey i'll just mention two things we took
uh nominations from the public we got
hundreds of them
the number one woman mentioned most
often by nominations from the public
pat summitt oh legendary coach
university of tennessee lady volunteers
let me mention another woman who who i i
did not know about until this project
felicita
mendez who was distressed in the 1940s
by the segregated schools
in california that her three children
were being forced to attend
she and her husband pursued a landmark
legal action that really